hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on for tonight again
for another upload and today we're gonna
be talking about the best places to farm
materials in fortnight getting materials
is very essential in fortnight Battle
Royale because it can help you with the
building basis or when you're being
attacked in it's a very key component in
for tonight and running out of materials
is a very bad idea and will definitely
if you want a disadvantage in any fight
and as well for tonight obviously has a
very destructive environment and
everything in the game that can be
broken down can be broken down into
three materials wood brick or metal in
today's video I'm going to show you some
good locations for each material and
we're to mine them quick tip before
getting started hitting the circles
while harvesting not only breaks down
the structure you're hitting faster but
it also yields more materials in the
clip shown I cut down a tree normally
and then cut down the other tree hitting
only the circles and I got more wood
faster and more in terms of capacity and
amount for the tree when I only hit the
circles
so definitely aim for those circles and
get more materials I wouldn't stress on
hitting the circle every single time and
taking your time if your aim is good
enough and your accuracy and your sharp
movement is good then that's fine but if
you're trying really hard and it takes
you way too long to hit the circles then
just wail at it it's way easier that way
beginning on to the first topic we have
wood for would I recommend destroying
the bushes and fences these are usually
located in named areas such as salty
retail Pleasant and our key fatal and
greasy and other named areas in the map
there is a lot of fences and bushes
around the map the fences and bushes
usually go down between one and two hits
and give a lot of wood I believe around
7 to 11 if I'm not mistaken about one or
two hits so you're going to be getting a
lot of wood very quickly since fences
usually go around the perimeter of
houses and there's a lot of them another
good source of wood is these pallets
which can be located at the factory
between retail and dusty as well at the
shipping container which is above retail
and below whaling woods I also forgot to
mention that they are also in dusty as
well but they are a lot bigger but
regardless they are still there as well
as inside of houses which is an amazing
source for wood since each object in
there roughly is wood and it takes about
one hit to destroy and there's a lot of
many objects inside as well like closets
containers random [ __ ] like that inside
houses you can clear out the interior of
a house and get a lot of wood that way
next up we're gonna be moving to is
brick and
bricky you should definitely drop in
your tomato talent for the most amount
of break possible to go where I landed
in the clip everything you see while I'm
skydiving basically in gray is brick
material there is a shitload of brick by
the tunnel above the tunnel around the
tunnel all that [ __ ] going toward dusty
even by whaling and even where I'm going
with this big-ass tree surrounding the
tree is these stone structures and if
all of them are destroyed i roughly came
out with 400 and only about a minute or
two minutes just to destroy all of them
like I said this isn't the only area
that you can get this brick though these
stones that you're that I'm destroying
in the clip are basically found
everywhere they're usually just out in
the middle of nowhere so you basically
can just start walking roughly toward
the northeast of the map I found out
which is really good where I found these
locations they seem to be a lot of these
stone structures around there and then
the last one is metal a quick source for
metal that I found out is the fenced in
area that's really tiny by retail as
well as the one by the basketball court
near that dog house that air vents
kitchen sinks the shelves in retail as
well as cars are also a very good source
for metal as well since they are
destroyed very quickly and give nice
resources but be aware though if you are
going to hit the car if you hit the car
the alarm will go off alerting your
nearby enemies to your position so be
very quick with it or don't hit it at
all if you have a better specific area
for these objects whether that be metal
brick or wood and there's some other
place that's better than what I
mentioned the lot definitely leave it
down in the comments below but that
that's going to end this very short
video hope you guys did enjoy like the
video if you did really just help me out
subscribe if you're new I'm doing a lot
of these guides for for tonight even
though these seem to be way over doing a
lot of people are doing them I thought I
would recap these regardless anyway I
got a gun guides coming out apparently
there's a guided missile launcher coming
to Fort night tomorrow which is
absolutely [ __ ] crazy
so if I managed to pick that up in a few
of my matches I'll try to do a guide on
that weapon that might take a little bit
of time because I heard that it's an
only gold tier weapon regardless I'm
gonna be doing gun guy it's new point of
interest guys and all that type of stuff
guides and tips and all that beautiful
stuff around fortnight my two most
recent videos are gonna be on screen if
you guys do want to check those out and
with that guys hope you have a great
rest your day and peace out